[Musique]
sur ce marché lillois
si l'on demande aux passants les règles
précises de ce nouveau confinement
difficile d'avoir une réponse claire je
ne sais pas non j'en sais rien toi tu
sais on sait pas premier sujet
d'incompréhension les attestations
dérogatoire doit-on en avoir une pour
sortir si oui laquelle
et où peut-on la télécharger le flou
demeure dans les 16 départements
concernés des déplacements sont limités
à une zone de 10 km mais les sorties en
extérieur se font sans attestation est
sans limite de temps on rappelle que le
couvre feu est passé à 19 heures dans
toute la france je fais un petit regret
c'est le genre de chez moi je peux aller
chez le coiffeur pour faire mes mèches à
un brushing passé chez le chocolatier
pour m'acheter des pralines faire un
saut au magasin de cigarettes pour
m'acheter des recharges pour mouvoir
potter marc était chez le fleuriste pour
acheter un bouquet baguenauder à la fnac
pour feuilleter les derniers bouquins
sortie m'acheter la dernière playstation
dans un magasin informatique mais pas
question admet être payé en danger on
peut en me payant un jean ou en réparant
une paire de pompes
absurde absurde le type qui a inventé
une attestation pour sortir de chez lui
mais faut pour le pendre quel est le
pays le plus heureux du monde charles
pas la france mais non pour la quatrième
année consécutive c'est la finlande qui
conserve son titre classement de l'onu
qui se base sur plusieurs critères le
pibe le niveau de solidarité les
libertés individuelles ou encore la
corruption et le haut du classement
reste inchangé cette année derrière la
finlande on trouve le danemark la suisse
et l'islande
la france n'est que 21e mais petit
cocorico on gagne deux places alors on a
fâché matignon qui est en train
d'appeler nom et sur l'a 10 ans ici
parce que j'ai dit faut le pendre tout à
l'heure bon il va vous avez 4 l ai dit
c'est du second degré mais c'est très
révélateur comme comme commander
réaction si les gens de matignon savait
comment pas parler vrai les vrais gens
si j'ose dire
c'est une expression c'est du second
degré ça se dit parfois comme ça faut le
prendre mais ont évidemment qu'on va pas
aller le pendre quand même poser une
bâche hawk a annoncé samedi sur twitter
qu'elle était positive au co vide une
annonce qui a déclenché un début de
polémique
oui car quelques heures avant son tweet
annonçant son test positif la ministre
avait publié un autre message deux
photos en compagnie de michel sardou
on la voit remettre les insignes de
commandeur de la légion d'honneur et sur
les photos on voit clairement que les
distances ne sont pas respectées
roselyne bachelot touche michel michel
sardou celui ci ne porte pas de masque
on m'a refilé cette saloperie en même
temps que les titre de commandeur je
suis commandeur qu'ovide bon c'est
plutôt qu'elle était dans la salle des
césar au pardon comment c'est pourquoi
vous dites ça passe comme ça peut-être
calmer pendant ces braves gens mais un
autre point dans l'agenda de roselyne
bachelot a suscité des réactions
vendredi soir juste avant l'annoncé de
son test positif elle assistait à
l'opéra bastille à une représentation
sans public
captés par des caméras en vue d'une
diffusion télé et là encore comme le
montrent des photos publiées par
médiapart roselyne bachelot a salué les
artistes
certes elle porte un masque mais elle
est collée agglutinés avec les artistes
qu'elle souhaite
sound est malade comme homme visiblement
le second degré ne passe pas je ne
souhaite à ganges d'être malade mais si
des gens pouvaient être confiné de la
parole par exemple tous ceux qui étaient
aux césars faites attention parce qu'on
va vous demander que ce soit vous - on
vous demandera
[Musique]
je suis passé à la casserole
c'est un prix me faire sauter comme une
petite folle et champignons
j'ai eu vent d'un certain nombre de
mariages qui se déroule match bien comme
si le mariage d'églantine et et benjamin
pouvait pas attendre à une seconde tu te
dis quoi cocteau je suis bon à mort
[Musique]
benjamin qui finit par épouser églantine
après connais depuis le lycée qui
connaît depuis le lycée après 35 cuite
qui ont fini par les convaincre que
finalement il se met peut-être quand
même assez pour me mettre au monde et
kiwi leurs enfants élevés aux kinois
tient peu droit quelqu'un c'est marrant
non je parlais de ma mère une flambée de
divorce en chine dit d'ondés oui en 2020
en 2020 on peut dire oui je le veux non
pas au mariage mais au divorce dont le
taux atteint des sommets vous lisiez
cette année en demi à 8,6 millions de
divorces ont été prononcés c'est presque
deux fois plus qu'en 2019
alors la faute en partie aux multiples
confinement corps est mis à mal la
sérénité des couples mais ça c'est un
petit peu partout quand il ne pleut pas
si mon goût trop j'espère que tu pourras
le voir bientôt en fait on dira j'espère
en tout cas je vous le dis j'ai parlé de
toi tu fais normalement tous les animaux
du monde veines du cou de situer du fait
des gratouiller les sites officiels
m'accepte par vcomment a battu dégage
faut pas me faire le distinguo entre les
choses graves et le discours
de tous les jours si on ne peut plus
rien dire à une femme parce qu'elle est
une femme je désolé ça c'est sexy ça
c'est insupportable
il y en eut une fille qu'elle est jolie
avec son décolleté moi je trouve ça
plutôt gentil oui toi pour toi c'est un
compliment
bah oui quand à faire honneur je
remarque qu'au niveau décolleté tu m'as
pas gâtés aujourd'hui parce que j'ai pas
là pour s'ils savaient que c'était pour
moi mais entre l'os et blairer ah ouais
ça fait un petit bout avec sa petite
cardiologie comment s'appelait la
blairer super misogyne verront attaque
balance temps forts s'étaient
embrouillés toi et moi il ya 4 ou 5 ans
parce que tu avais sous les mashups
devant tout le monde tu te souviens tu
te souviens pas du tout tu te souviens
pas mais pas du tout ben tu vois moi je
m'en souviens ouais donc tu avait
soulevé ma jupe et je l'avais mal pris
je t'avais même je crois frapper ou je
sais pas quoi du tout mais ça par
exemple est ce que tu leur ferait
aujourd'hui oui
[Musique]
même si tu parles mal défi je sais qu'au
fond tu as compris balançons quoi
peut-être ça changera
alençon quoi
est ce qui est difficile pour moi c'est
quand on dit que je fais un pot de
fleurs aval pots de fleurs elles ont mis
un nouveau pot de fleurs une fois en jeu
n'étaient pas là on va remplacer par une
plante verte
ah oui tu as fait retirer un conte de
fées le petit château
sauf que je suis pas une fille je la
fais tu as fait ça fait chier